rising cost of rent across the valley
certainly making it harder for
low-income seniors and and so many
others to make ends meet this morning
construction on a new apartment complex
will break ground however and the
mission is to bring more affordable
housing especially for our senior
community hector mejia live at eastern
and washington right now with a look at
the project hi hector
hillary good morning and here's how
important this is we're told there are
only 16 low-income units available in
the valley for every 100 low-income
households and this project here will
bring more opportunities to this part of
the valley here by eastern and
washington we're in an area where a fire
tore through an apartment complex for
low-income seniors back in october and
although it's not tied to the new
complex they'll both serve a vulnerable
population side by side the future
golden rule senior apartments will build
60 units for 19 million dollars during
the first phase the non-profit
neighborhood housing services of
southern nevada says while they are
trying to help our community they're
also battling social stigma around
affordable housing
not a lot of people want to see some of
these affordable housing projects go up
because as soon as you say affordable
housing or you say section 8 oh god
forbid it's it's
it's got a stigma around it
the new complex is scheduled to open in
one year next february it also got
funding from city and county grants and
the non-profit is expecting a large
volume of applications before it opens
it'll serve a population for of seniors
who make an annual income of sixteen
thousand dollars a year for a household
of one reporting live hector mejia live
local now